now one of the things that happens as
you guys know is that the democrats can
basically get away with anything they
can pretty much get away with anything
because the media runs cover for them so
if trump had had any of these sort of
gaffes if trump had said i mean really
think about it for just a second if
trump had said
uh that this man putin cannot remain in
power the front page of every single
newspaper would say that donald trump is
leading us into world war iii that we
are about to have nukes dropped on our
major cities the world is going to come
to an end etc etc but instead they
basically even though he muddles it and
confuses it he says i didn't say it then
he repeats it they kind of run cover for
him
and nobody runs cover like a good anchor
over at cnn here is don
lamont let's say what we
my interpretation of this as i said over
the weekend right after the president
said it being here in the region in
ukraine the president is saying exactly
what most of the world feels about
vladimir putin now he did not in that
speech say that vladimir putin should be
removed or we're going to take him out
of power he said this man should not
remain in power
you see these ridiculous semantic games
now first off don lemon pretends he's a
journalist he often says he's a
journalist and i want to be very clear i
often say it i am not a journalist i am
a guy
who sits in a room with a couple other
people and in the morning i try to think
about what i want to talk about and i
tell you the best
uh stuff i can tell you right i try to
analyze things the best possible they
translate some of the nonsense and then
hopefully you listen and then you go
about your daily life don lemon pretends
he's a journalist would be which would
be an impartial arbiter of the truth and
he would present it to you and walk away
but as he just said there he's analyzing
what the president said so he's the
implication is even though he said this
man cannot remain in power he didn't
really mean this man can't remain in
power he just sort of said that but
that's not the thing that he meant
and also the implication also that that
no one would believe that which is also
what bite is no one would believe that i
said the thing that i just said
they're gaslighting all of us at all
times but you're not gonna believe this
another guy on cnn this jake tapper and
he's he's just a democrat activist who
you know he's he's an anchor but okay so
be it he sort of almost kinda gets it
the way he asks this question maybe a
little caitlyn president biden suggested
that no one
could have interpreted his remarks as
calling for regime change
of course jake many people raised that
question of whether or not that is what
he was advocating for at the end of the
speech but today he says he is not
walking back his statement that
president putin cannot remain in power
but jake he also says he is not stating
a new policy from the united states
government
as you can see i've put on my news
anchor glasses so that i can analyze
that clip properly now uh you got the
don lemon over there saying no no that's
not what he said nobody believes that's
what he said then jake tapper actually
asked a somewhat proper question maybe
it's because of the glasses which is hey
maybe some people kind of took it the
wrong way you see what's going on here
we got we got a problem but the endless
chaos absolutely continues over the last
couple days like it's seriously
this is bananas level
stuff did you ever see the woody allen
movie bananas were entering into the
bananas level of all of this uh and even
obama
era people uh leon panetta who was the
defense secretary under barack obama uh
he even thinks that joe biden is causing
some confusion and that might be a bit
of a problem at this point in the game
you've really got to keep your messages
very simple and very direct and i think
this created some confusion
that wasn't helpful
yes i mean president macron has said as
much this has created i think more than
confusion in terms of the tension that
it has for people trying to negotiate
with putin
you know shit's bad when cnn is starting
to make a little bit of sense and
they're bringing on people to actually
say something honest because they want
by default position they want to run
cover that is the the nature of the
network so when they're actually asking
the right questions jake tapper you ask
the right question
when they are actually bringing on a
former defense secretary from obama who
joe biden may not remember it but joe
biden was his number two guy he was the
vp
and he's saying this is causing
confusion then there's a real problem in
the country